so since 1970 obesity has tripled in
adults and almost tripled in children
okay so the answer is in the food
statistics I want to see if you could
figure this out so this data is based in
America 2014 on what an average American
consumes per day I put a link down below
to see the entire report so let's see if
you could figure this out okay
number one vegetables an average
American consumes 1.6 cups of vegetable
per day protein 7.1 ounces fat 63 grams
daily so we get forty four point seven
grams of vegetable fat and fourteen
point seven grams of saturated fat
grains point four eight pounds that's a
half a pound a day 174 pounds a year
sugar 23 teaspoons per day or 131 pounds
per year now this is added sugar okay
it's not the sugar within the food so
what do you think go ahead and type it
in the comment section I'll wait for
your answer we'll give you a couple
minutes actually this is recorded I
can't do that but it's pretty obvious to
me hey look at this
vegetables 1.6 cups now we need 7 to 10
cups okay fat 63 grams that's not
unreasonable this is too high though
vegetable oil because this actually is
soy canola corn GMO this is a problem
okay grains a half a pound a day is that
too much that is way too much half a
pound of grains and you're talking a lot
of refined grains as well and then we
have added sugar 23 teaspoons per day is
that excessive how many is acceptable
less than one zero so I don't know if
it's just me but it's so obvious of
what's causing this we need to increase
the vegetables we need to cut down the
vegetable oil we need to eliminate these
two right here
and this will go away so some people
will tell you it's the saturated fat but
we're only consuming fourteen point
seven grams of saturated fat every
single day that is not the problem these
are the problem so go ahead and type
down your comments your opinion below
I'm really curious what you think about
this data so we've been getting a lot of
success stories but I don't have your
success story yet so click the link down
below and upload you before and after I
want to actually hear about your success
story I want to see your before and
afters and every week we do featured
success stories so click the link down
below and share your success